It's being called the toxic haze.
For weeks, northern Thailand has been rated
one of the most-polluted regions in the world.
The worst wildfires in years combined with
traditional crop-burning practices are blanketing
the area in smog.
DW correspondent Charlotte Chelsom-Pill travelled
to Chiang Rai province, where thousands of
people have been left gasping for air and
tourist numbers have plunged because of the
pollution.
It doesn't take long for a small blaze like
this to turn into a rampant wildfire.
That’s something regional Fire Chief Prathip
Choemsom knows only too well.
This month Chiang Rai in northern Thailand
saw some of the most devastating forest fires
in years.
And the danger is not over yet.
This is a new fire.
The trees are very dry here
Massive areas of land, burnt turned to ash.
And the damage doesn’t end there.
This is what happens when you mix forest fires
with heavy pollution.
It’s being called a toxic haze.
Lingering smoke and noxious fumes, creating
a dangerous cocktail.
For weeks Chiang Rai has recorded some of
the worst air quality in the world.
Hitting the most vulnerable the hardest.
85 year old Bunlert Jansangphen has lived
here all his life.
He and his wife say the pollution has never
been this bad.
I couldn’t see clearly.
It made my eyes water.
They were really painful.
I'm afraid the smog could get even worse.
And last even longer.
Pollution-related health problems have surged.
Health workers say they’re struggling to
cope.
It’s very bad extremely bad.
I wasn’t prepared for this.
Sometimes even I can’t breathe well and
have to get medical help/ No matter what we
do, it’s not enough.
Emergency Services blame the wildfires on
an usually dry summer.
There’s fear here that the fires could become
the norm.
And authorities want to be ready.
PTC: this fire team doesn’t want to be caught
off guard again.
They’re building dozens of dams, like this
one across these mountains.
They’re aimed at stopping fires from spreading
and holding water to put them out.”
People here are now just praying for the rainy
season to hit and put an end to this toxic
nightmare.
For this year at least.